we're living in a world that is so
polarized where everything is black and
white
um where we think that uh uh you know if
i'm right you must be wrong
um and the reality is the world is very
gray um
the world is not black and white uh you
know and and very often there is no
right or wrong very often um
uh and so and i think if you look at our
politicians
you know i i think we're quick to blame
our politicians but i think our
politicians are a reflection of us
i think quite frankly you know if we're
worried that that
that the world is polarized and our
politicians are dividing us i think
that's us
you know we complain that they don't
listen we complain that they judge we
complain that
you know uh they they pit one group
against another for personal gain well
that's kind of what we've been doing for
for years you know
and they pretend to be like us so they
can get elected
so i think if we're disgusted by the
states of our nations and we're
disgusted
and disappointed by how polarized we are
and almost everyone is and by the way
google doesn't help
because the algorithm attempts to show
you things that it thinks you want to
see
so if you lean one political direction
and you really care about finding
what the balance truth is whatever you
google will show you your political
leaning
and and and the opposite for for the
other side
so uh uh you know i think it starts at
home i think we
all as individuals have to do a better
job of listening we have to
learn to be less judgmental we have to
accept that
that that two people can be right or at
least try to understand
where they come from uh uh and
understand that that there's a reason
for you know
nobody thinks there no nobody when we
keep calling other groups evil
nobody thinks they're evil everybody
thinks they're on the side of good
everybody
um uh and to try and understand
what that means to and get to the root
is where you find common ground
you know i'm very proud of a there's one
particular friendship i have with
um uh with a friend in
here and we are on polar dip opposite
sides of the political spectrum
and we have very different beliefs about
a lot of things in the world
but we completely love each other and
care about each other because at the end
of the day we share
a lot of the same values and we're
interested in each other we learn from
each other we ask each other hard
questions and we listen as opposed to
trying to be right and convince the
other person that they're wrong
and let me be clear those conversations
are difficult
you know when people say things that
trigger you and for you to react with
curiosity rather than anger
or to call somebody or to show interest
in their point of view and understand it
rather than tell them that they're wrong
or stupid
you know i mean that takes a lot of hard
work and and let's be honest they don't
teach us those skills at school
we don't learn their schools those
skills at work so where are we learning
those skills
you know we have to learn those skills
and quite frankly i think companies
should teach those skills
companies should teach listening and
effective confrontation and how to have
difficult conversations
and how to give and receive feedback
because not only will it
help us at work because all of those
things matter at work but it'll actually
help us be better human beings
so believe it or not i actually think
business could be the solution
to the problems we have in our world
because our government's not going to
teach us those skills
our schools aren't teaching us those
skills people aren't taking it upon
themselves to learn those skills
but if we have to learn those skills at
work well guess what those skills get
used every in
in all aspects of our lives and
eventually we'll get politicians that
reflect that as well